ドロップ切り替えがリーグパさがわかるときこの動画ね
なぁ俺がねマミーの友達から釣り合いの留守名参加息子さんに向けて言ってくれって
言うことをその娘さん息子さんのお母さん
ずた会で俺のマミーに入ってで俺のマミーがラインドルに言いなさいと言われたって
言うな
あれでございます俺のマミーの知り合いの娘さん息子さん見てるかい
いつもありがとう
続いて今回はまぁちょっと軽くお話でございますまあタイトルにもある通りですね勉強
のやる気が出ないってことが多い受験中にもかかわらずちょうどたまるで岩田ば夏休み
前の定期テストをやってる人とか行った人
やる前の1ぐらいの人が飛びいると思うんですけどもひとまずそのテストが終わったら
夏休みでございますみんな夏休みへようこそ
甘いこと言って戯れ十剣聖大事ながここからです
夏休みに入ってから2件線本当に勝負なので
皆さん頑張ってくださいっていうわけであのなんて言われてる間ってなんてくれてんだ
けどそれぞれその子供たちの勉強のやる気を子を起こさせるみたいなこと言われたらで
置く形にちょっと僕がどうやって勉強してたかってことをこんな日なんでをしようと
思いますよかったら是非聴いてください
いいかもよ私はずでしょぶっちゃけた話
バカでございまして天才だけど天才で天才で天才ですけども
まあ学生というそのかっこいいののコミュニティの中ではバカでしたなのでも全然松来
もします失敗だらけなんですけどもなんとか今も元気に生きておりますで今からいう話
はボケがすごい人間だからって話じゃなくて誰なもできる話でございますそういうこと
でなんと僕自身が服率だったってわけじゃないっていうことでます聞いてください源隆
受験勉強5個
いいというものをを据えようと思いますねこれはですねえと注意事項としてまず受験生
以外でも使えると思います今飛ぶの勉強する気がない人ってすごい多いと運勢はもう
いうわけでは薄着
スマホゲーム
スマホゲームスマホゲームスマホスマホスマホ
州の入学をいかにたつけて勉強するかっていうのが大事だと思いますがどんな気持ちで
勉強してたかっていうのはちょっとねーさんにお伝えしようと思いますでもう一つ
そういう事項としてこれで正しい方法とは限りません皆それぞれさの音やる気の出し方
っていうのがあるのでこれはあくまで僕はこう考えながらやってたよっていう
案外の一つに過ぎないのでこれが正しいということもないし人それぞれ
その自分が頑張れるね心の持つようっていうやつがあるのでまぁあくまで参考までに4
つあるんですけど僕はこの4つを心に叩き込んで受験勉強乗り切ったというお話で
ございます電場のやる気がでない人
受験勉強と近い人よかったら聴いてみて下さいねないこ
きたぜガー
こうは嫌い走ってきましたまさに名前の通りです僕実は学校があんまり好きではあり
ません先生が怖いです集団で動くのが好きではありませんいろんなになってる僕実は
そんなに学校が好きじゃなくてむしろどっちかというと嫌いですの部活に対した後受験
勉強中になんですけどもう基本的に僕はもうあれですよおづぎ終わったら走って帰って
ます
学校からいる意味がないんで学校思いやる人作業みたいな感じでしたらと言ってました
のでもね先生方はちょっと準備してくれているんですよその受験勉強用に向けた報酬と
かさあ籠の中授業とか準備してくれてるんですけども僕は一切出ませんでした出る意味
を感じなかったです
僕はね豪華の話ですからね僕は出る意味が感じなかったですねなぜかと言いますと
要するに同じ偏差値同じレベルの生徒たちが集まってるわけじゃないですかその学校に
はねそういう形で同じ授業を受けて同じ勉強の仕方をしてても上には登れないなと思い
ました
受験美女的というのは学校内だけじゃないんですよもう全国の全員が姉もライバルなの
で
同じレベルの奴らと同じレベルの勉強せてもたぶんこのレベルから上にはいけないなと
思ったのでほしいの授業は一切無視して全部でズームかひたすら自己流で勉強しており
ましたという話でございますまあそれで成績が上がるか上がらないかは内容とかけた
時間次第でございます集団行動はあんまり好きじゃなかった2つ目一人でやりましょう
受験勉強ね勉強は1人
やるものですさっき愛なんて必要ないです全員的ですねあ友達と協力しやってやってた
人もいたんですけどももし酸素でさに片方が成績上がって片方が成績落ちちゃったりし
たらなんかやな気持ちになりそうだなとか一人でこっそり思ってて部活引退してからの
受験期間中はもう学校でもすべてにおいて基本的に一人で行動しておりました
寂しかったけれどそれぐらいしないと誘惑に負けちゃうんですよね学校にいるときも
なるべくに一人で号ずっと参考書とか読んでました
懐かしいなそれぐらいの覚悟で僕は勉強しておりますまあとりあえず一人でやるのは
凄いモチベーションになります僕は誰の目も気にしなくて一人で好きなだけ勉強してい
ます一人にあるっていう話なんですけど果たして僕はどこで勉強していたか学校は
みんなでたむろしててなんか気分悪い感やだった家では誘惑が多すぎて無理僕は実は
ずっと図書館で勉強しておりましたが
終わったらすぐ図書館に行って無言で一人で黙々と勉強してました3つ目頑張っている
のは内緒にしましょう今別ですけど高校の時は頑張ってるのがねちょっと恥ずかしい
ことだと思ってて頑張ってるのがすごいだろ馬鹿らしいというか頑張って結果が出
なかった時が過ぎんカッコ悪いなと思っててまあそういうのもあってですね多分頑張っ
てる2
部分っていうのなんか誰かに見られたくなかったのもあるしそれで訂正が上がらなかっ
たっていうのは誰かに見られてもすごい嫌だし頑張ってるのはぶくっずっと内緒にして
ますがみんなで一緒に頑張って勉強してたので自分だけ成績が上がってなかったんです
ねこれ恥ずかしい思いをするんだと思っててこれもたぶん僕の心が弱かっただけです誰
にも言ってねーな多分頑張ったらで失敗するっていうのがすごく嫌だったので頑張っ
ているのは僕は内緒にしてましたマァリンダウ目を気にせず頑張るためにという意味で
そして最後4つ目です
これは僕が何で3面が好きかって言うのにすごい由来します
頑張っているのはない子だし誰も気づいてないと思うんですけども
シャーペンだけはいつも見てくれています
今ちょっと頭おかしい人だと思ったしとても実際そうなんですよ
いやそれも年間がぼかせ一人でずっと勉強してたり頑張ってるっていうのを誰にも言わ
なかったら
なっていかなかったときそれこそ何も残らないなと思うわけですよ
勉強してる自分を誰も知らないからさうまくいかなかったら上手くいかなかったら
みんなそれが当たり前みたいな目で見てくるだろうする一人で勉強しているとこれが
本当に正しいのかすごい不安になることもあると思います
血管
たならない時もあるしそういう時もすごい孤独で何かねすらいって思うときもあると
思います僕もありましたあったんですけども勉強するときそれだったしたらを見てくれ
てないして自分の頑張りが誰も吸ってないと思うんですけども
いつも君の手元には
サーフィンがいると思います
いやマジな話熱闘た船だから俺シャーペイ好きなんだろうの一人で勉強してるわけなん
ですけれども必ず手元には仲間が一人います誰も見えないし誰も自分がどれだけ勉強し
たかっていうことも知ってないと思うんですけどさぁ点だけは勉強している時はどんな
時でも常に
頑張ってる自分を見てくれてると思い約3分にものすぐ情熱とか愛情があるのは多分
多分受験中にねシャーペンに向かって心でこう語りかけてた自分がいたのが誰も原因だ
と思います
カナリヤベストから離れ矢部したがかなりやべえ人なんですけどもまぁお守りみたいな
もんでしょうこのはじめリュージュ顕微鏡の極意はとても孤独でつらいものですづらい
ものなんですけどもシャーペンだけはずっと取れた旧頑張ってくれた彼を見てくれた
ようなサーフィンを信じて俺は受験いきますかこれ本当に参考になるのかな
なるべくかっこいい自分で最高のゴールに行きたいなと思って
高
郵便情報になりましたはいという感じでございますこれがで参考になるかどうかは僕は
わかんないんですけど次元者の皆さん
受験は夏がマジで勝負でございますこの方法が参考になるかわかんないんですけども件
勉強は自分との戦い自分に作って米国のみんなをぶっ倒してください
中安効率な勉強ではありません高い点数を取った人が合格する2件制度
皆さんが笑顔で春を迎えられるように応援しております
じゃじゃーん
七海
これでいいかい
しています